hola muy buenos días todavía verdad este
pues contento estar aquí mi plática es
un poquito más personal de las mis dos
compañeros anteriores siempre he pensado
que en la parte creativa no hay pues un
camino no hay una instrucción que seguir
por eso este nombre así me platica
y les voy a dar cinco consejos que no
tienen que seguir este decía borges que
pues el destino cuando el hombre se da
cuenta de su destino es cuando descubre
qué es lo que va a ser o el resto de su
vida y yo cuando estaba en secundaria
que sabía cada uno de los que están
arriba
la generación 250 pero no me van a caber
ahí fue que me di cuenta que lo mío era
la música y que sí o sí iba a seguir
este hacia ese camino no y pueden primer
consejo es que no se preparen que hay
que aprender haciendo no entonces es
aventarnos al abismo a pesar de no saber
este este fue mi bueno mi primer grupo
más o menos con el que empecé y este y
pues la verdad cantaba horrible no sabía
ni una nota musical sin embargo pues
como me gustaba y me apasionaba me
aventé no entonces
empecé a aprender haciendo y a toparme
con cosas ya esté ir escalando poco a
poco este yo pensé que con este primer
grupo iba a conquistar al mundo y cuando
me di cuenta que en realidad era el
primer grado de la escuela no éste es
importante pues también estar
determinado y seguir y seguir y seguir
es como ven pues hacíamos nuestros
pinitos aquí en el barrio antiguo
ponemos nuestros pósters ahí este
hacíamos nosotros demos
pues así éramos en la casa de mis papás
ensayábamos luego tuve otro grupo y otro
grupo de otro grupo y si dicen que
se aprende de los fracasos y aunque se
aprende yo creo que se aprende más de
los éxitos entonces hay que tener éxito
para aprender más rápido y luego también
no me fui enfrentando a esas cosas en
una de ellas siempre había querido ser
como díaz y nunca me aventaba hasta que
me invitaron en argentina a hacer pues
un dj dije que sí sin pensarlo que tenía
enfrente y cuando me aventaron una
discoteca así como de 1500 personas en
arriba del escenario no sabía ni mezclar
nada y ahí fue que aprendí
y así igual también nos fuimos
aprendiendo a hacer cosas hasta que
llegamos a kim kye que es como mi
proyecto de vida más intenso que he
tenido hasta ahora y pues aprendí no
a tocar frente a un bar de 20 personas
luego decide el logo de mil hasta que
nos encontramos con este tipo de
monstruo de estadios no de mil cabezas y
pues una cosa muy importante es ser
necio no determinado para pues para
poder llegar porque pues sí como te digo
te topas con muchas cosas pero hay que
ser necios y hay que aprender haciendo
mi segundo consejo es que usen drogas
o sea no literalmente
que usen la experiencia que usen los
viajes en la parte creativa lo más
importante son las ideas y muchas veces
como escritor como pintor o como músico
como cineasta pues te encuentras con esa
pared con ese lienzo blanco que es el
riders lo que le llaman después a la
experiencia sí es muy importante es muy
importante ponerte en situaciones
incómodas ponerte en este
pues no sean cosas que experiencias que
no tengas para que te salgan ideas
nuevas y si o si es es un fake o sea si
funciona y si es necesario yo puse como
ejemplo esta portada este disco este una
experiencia pues que tuve fuerte fue
como la primer muerte de un familiar
cercano era mi abuelo este y esa
experiencia la transforma en una canción
que se llama donde van los muertos que
vienen en este disco y pues que al final
de cuentas fue un regalo no de mi abuelo
que hizo que vendiéramos discos y
pudiera pagar la renta y todo por los
próximos 20 años
entonces también si dar la contra no dar
la contra es este sin voltear las las
ideas que ya existen y ese dar la contra
muchas veces es lo que nos da esa pauta
para para la creatividad a mí me gusta
cuando a mis compañeros de la banda
no les gustan mis ideas y dice que son
ideas buenas ideas que
pues que pueden cambiar cosas
y mi tercer consejo es pues qué
que terminen antes de tiempo que no le
den tanta importancia a la perfección
sino que hay que seguir haciendo y estar
cómodo no con que salga una cosa sale un
disco sale un cuadro sale una película
sale tu libro y ya salió ya dio vida ya
terminar ese proyecto y te enfrentas al
que sigue no entonces muchas veces nos
tardamos años en hacer los discos en
hacer los proyectos estos son discos de
nosotros estos son un poco de pues
también o de lass
las consecuencias de sacar material y
material material nos han incluido en
muchos soundtracks the book of life
admisión
son desde seis películas gringas como
mexicanas como amarte duele etcétera
etcétera
este juego de vídeo comerciales de
nissan de onda de amazon
soundtracks de series dexter weeds si es
a gossip girl etcétera etcétera y así no
estoy como muy presumido pero son
cosas que se generan a partir de sacar
tu material no también muchos festivales
como coachella el lollapalooza outside
lands este vive latino rock al parque
etc etc pero bueno pues este es el cual
iba en el tercero este
que esto es eso no es concretar es
terminar las cosas antes de tiempo
y aquí estamos en el estudio como que yo
estoy grabando entonces que te valga
madre o sea que salga tu proyecto que
salga tu disco que salga tu lo que estés
haciendo y no importa si tiene sus
pequeños detalles nunca va a llegar a
ser perfecto entonces es sacarlo no que
es lo importante
mi cuarto consejo es que tengas una
doble vida y este es mi favorito es
expander t
mi mamá que está aquí presente me decía
el que mucho abarca poco aprieta
y creo que ese concepto lo tire a la
basura y
me gustó expander o no porque estaba yo
en el escenario y de las primeras cosas
que hice fue empezar a producir mi
profesión no la producción del show no
solamente es tocar y cantar sino cómo se
prenden las luces de dónde vienen las
pantallas es lo que se va a generar en
el contenido qué es lo que va primero
que toda esa producción se da cuenta que
pues me dice experto sin querer y otra
forma pues también era bueno voy a
investigar a ver qué computadora quizás
nanana nanana y empecé a armar mis
michelle citó dentro de mi show no
entonces lo primero que hice fue éste
fue agarré un sistema de cámaras de
seguridad y las empecé a implementar en
todos lados del escenario incluyendo mi
micrófono y como que empezó agarrar
vuelo y hasta la gente los empezó a
copiar y así y el año pasado
ya con todo ese expertise me aventé todo
el sound nuevo de kinky
que tuve ventaja de que fueron mis
primeros clientes digamos los pude
convencer y ese todo un sistema de
pantallas y cubos con ruedas que iban a
jalar no sabía si va a salir o no pero
les vendí la idea y este y pues funcionó
el show quedó pues padrísimo
este son estos cubos que como les digo
se van moviendo por todo el escenario y
que de hecho aquí tenemos un primer
vídeo que les voy a poner para que
tengan un poquito la idea y luego les
sigo contando a ver si funciona
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
a
ah
[Música]
bueno ya será un poquito para que lidere
un foco y de ahí ese es el primer
concierto este primer concierto fue en
el vive latino del año del 17
al siguiente día me pasaron a llamar los
otros grupos para que les hiciera sus
shows entonces dije bueno pues por qué
no y empezamos a hacer varias
colaboraciones digamos el primero que
ese evento fue don lupe y les hice
existe el show bronco
luego a los ángeles azules este es el
coachella esté ahorita terminamos uno de
moenia tenemos otros tres shows en en
producción que estamos como ya
desarrollando para grupos de todos no de
pop hasta donde el grau no está cumbia
está de todo y ha sido con una
experiencia increíble porque
pues además de poner las pantallas luces
la sala la empezamos a hacer mucho
contenido que es lo que se ve en las
pantallas es como la iglesia que se ven
las pantallas entonces abrí una pequeña
empresa que además de hacer esto es
hacer contenido para pues para todo
aún ser videoclips y se empecé a dirigir
videoclips a partir de esto como que una
cosa lleva a la otra sin querer y empecé
a dirigir videoclips del primero que
vieron fue uno de miranda y luego bueno
con reik este con este artistas de
argentina usamos hacer postproducción
para grupos de españa para psoe para
bueno para kim kye también se las vendía
otra vez
y terminé con una empresa de
postproducción y filmación y comprando
cámaras y teniendo un equipo ahí de
animadores y les voy a enseñar un
pequeño reel de lo que hemos estado
haciendo en los últimos años que es el
siguiente vídeo que tenemos para ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
sí
[Música]
aquí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y música
tiempos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
[Música]
bueno así que ya saben si necesitan un
comercial para su marca su empresa ya
saben a quién hablar sí
y así que pues bueno es este
la parte no debe ir queriendo más y más
que es este esto no es expandirnos hacia
estos nuevos momentos hacia esas nuevas
experiencias
creo que pues ya vivimos 80 años no sé
antes la gente que vivía 30-40 asideras
zapateros es que se especializaba en eso
ahora pero más tiempo tenemos la
tecnología tenemos todo a nuestro
alcance y podemos aprender y llegar a
hacer un montón de cosas mi siguiente y
último consejo era que se vayan de
fiesta
este la fiesta es el lugar donde
convives más intensamente con más gente
donde se hacen las amistades donde esté
se cierran hasta los negocios no
entonces la fiesta el convivio la
colaboración son como piezas muy
importantes dentro de la parte creativa
porque llegas a expander se llegas a
lugares que no puedes llegar solo y pues
para mí obviamente la mayor colaboración
o mis colegas del grupo pues han sido
una enseñanza en todos los aspectos y
gracias a que tengo estos cuatro
integrantes a que tengo estos cuatro
amigos con los que hago música y
viajamos estamos de tour pues he llegado
a donde estoy no creo que solos o
desconectados
no lo lograremos así que vayas de fiesta
y bien lo saben también los empresarios
que llevan a sus mejores clientes que
vienen de visita a la ciudad los llevan
los strip loops y este y ahí es donde se
cierran los negocios no
y pues sí esta colaboración estos
encuentros que hemos tenido con todos
sus artistas también me ha llevado a
escribir canciones para pues para otra
gente para otros géneros este desde el
pop de anahí y gloria trevi este hasta
buscó alternativas con los amigos
invisibles con este compacto de control
machete con la mala rodríguez hasta con
pepe aguilar con steps otra vez con mi
compadre de bronco este hasta con el
daddy yankee no esté como que hemos
recorrido por todos lados y siempre como
también bien lo saben mis papás me ha
gustado mucho la fiesta y creo que es él
es el este
pues es el lugar donde donde mejor
conectas con la gente y de verdad que sí
como que una vez mi novia me decía por
qué te quieres quedar tan tarde para que
entonces me puse a pensar y dijimos para
que el s p's y la verdad como que lo que
más me gusta de vivir es eso no es como
la conexión personal y real que sé que
se generan en la peda a las 4 de la
mañana este entonces les aconsejo que se
vayan de fiesta y que sigan bailando
hasta que marche muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]